let's talk a little bit about what's
going on on the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum we have surpassed 4,000
of our viewers and listeners discussing
politics with each other
politics and Pat scandals those are the
two primary general types of issues
discussed on our reddit discussion forum
you can sign up for free at david
pakman.com slash read it let's look at
some interesting conversations I spotted
this morning when looking around one is
trivia anthony scaramouche II was
actually the fourth person as the White
House communications director in the
Trump administration Sean Spicer had two
short stints that's true there have been
four White House communications
directors one of them Sean Spicer having
that role twice yeah in only six and
some portion of a month of Donald
Trump's presidency vary in size Sean
Spicer was working as the White House
press secretary and the communications
director at the same time that's right
and he couldn't even handle one of those
jobs so I don't know how he's supposed
to handle to know and also how could
scare Moochie handle anything was
another question but that's sort of a
different different topic also from our
reddit discussion forum a interesting
post about the aging liberal justices in
a conservative Supreme Court and it's an
interesting post about the possible
timing of future retiring from the
Supreme Court and really the Supreme
Court has proven that to be one of the
most important or I guess you would say
impactful ways that Donald Trump's
presidency could steer the future of
America yeah you think about Ginsburg
and Breyer getting up there in age I
mean I don't think they would willingly
retire at this point but you never know
circumstances could lead them to leaving
the court also from our reddit
discussion forum a post about the
importance of gender and gender studies
this is related to my interview on
Tuesday with a Professor Peter Bogosian
who is not a fan of gender studies in
schools he what he believes that they
are taught those departments are taught
by radical ideologues who should be
defunded and there was a very
interesting discussion about how gender
in studies is important in college also
from our reddit discussion forum about
the Peter Boghossian interview this is
just one example on-screen but they were
probably close to ten different threads
about different
specs of our conversation with Peter
Boghossian one of them this one said I
thought the full hour was a bit of a
miss don't get me wrong the guy is
interesting enough for an interview I
just don't think he was worth the full
hour interview although based on the
number of threads about the interview on
reddit that suggests it was compelling
to say the least
yes if some people loved it we're
changing it up short people love it
that's what I'm that's what I'm told by
the prime minister of Montenegro that's
who told me that one on the phone of
course don't ask me for proof that that
phone call ever happened lastly from the
reddit discussion forum a celebration
thread about 4,000 subscribers on reddit
yeah this started so small Pat I don't
know how long ago and now with the help
of moderators and the regular visits by
producer Pat and by me and by our intern
Brian is all over the reddit everybody's
all over reddit it is now surpassed
4,000 and that is a nice little online
community so I can stop making reddit
accounts and subscribing to the
subreddit them yeah yeah yeah you can
cancel your thirty eight hundred and
fifty accounts which represent almost
all of those four thousand subscribers
now that that's done